joining us now as their Shadow business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds
um hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program let's start
with those teaching union strikes and
potential strikes first of all should we
what impact is that going to have on
kids who are about to do their exams
well of course like any industrial
action it will be disruptive it'll have
an impact on people but it's not easy to
strike in this country workers are not
having an easy time they don't want to
lose pay and when you've got not just
this action but action in so many
different sectors it really comes down
to people using this as a last resort
and the fact is for most working people
in this country the last 13 years have
not been easy and they've been driven to
this and frankly the response from
government has got to be an
acknowledgment that that's the case that
they are the ones responsible when it
comes to Public Services they're going
to have to negotiate and simply trying
to legislate to pretend that this state
of affairs doesn't exist by the kind of
laws we're seeing proposed in Parliament
today it's a mistake it will work it
will actually make these disputes even
harder to resolve and so you know but I
object the most to to be honest is the
sense the government have that workers
themselves don't understand the
disruption that is taking place of
course they do but they have been driven
to this and the government's got to
understand that and if they don't
understand that frankly they'll never
get to the bottom of a resolution in any
of the sectors that are affected so you
do condone strike action during exam
period
I think any
working person only strikes as a last
resort and people particularly in public
services who love their job who seed as
a vocation they know the impact it will
have and nobody wants to see strikes
take place they can be resolved it does
require a willingness to negotiate but
frankly the point of strike is
disruption if the government doesn't
understand that it doesn't understand
anything so nobody wants to see strikes
take place but if the government isn't
willing to really appreciate why they
are taking place I'm afraid
there won't be a way to resolve them and
we've seen actually you know as you said
there's more hope in the railways a
little bit more of an acknowledgment
left in the government that they've got
to do something let's have some more of
that across the economy as a whole
so even during exam time is acceptable
well there will never be a time when
strike action in education isn't
disruptive to young people who are
studying you know there is no easy time
as it were to go on strike and yes it
will have a an impact on young people
there's no doubt about that but frankly
that the solution to that is rather than
condemning workers who feel driven to
take this action the solution to that is
getting down to negotiate and frankly we
haven't seen enough of that and the
reason for that in my view is that the
government are frankly embarrassed at
the state of Public Services after 13
years in power and they see in the
variety of industrial actions taking
place a chance to somehow use it as an
alibi to switch the blame onto workers
themselves to somehow say that's the
reason Public Services aren't performing
most people in this country will know
even when there isn't strike action
taking place a lot of Public Services
are not running to the degree that they
should do with the expectations people
have of them so let's not get into
condemning people let's resolve these
disputes and they won't take place let's
um talk about our beloved NHS should we
Your Leader yesterday saying the NHS
needs reform we're being told that part
of that could be the ditching of a GP
contracts I'm reading it in the paper
this morning that could cost
um an extra seven billion pounds well is
that really something that you want to
embark on at this stage
well what we want okay is a long-term
10-year plan for the NHS that addresses
the fact that it isn't working because
people wanted to work at the moment part
of our plans are for substantial extra
resources abolishing that the non-dong
tax regime for the super rich and using
that to for instance double the number
of doctors being trained but we've also
got to look at new ways of doing things
it's a consultation we're not being
prescriptive I think we've got to be
willing to look at new ways of doing
things like the NHS has always evolved
throughout its history specifically on
the issue rays of you know GPS becoming
direct employees of the NHS rather than
the partnership model there are already
and have been in the last few years
substantial changes that have taken
place to that model a lot of younger
Medics don't want to become GPS on the
old model we've seen sort of big
Healthcare interests come in and buy up
some GP practices so there is change
happening in this area so we've got to
look at that because it's happening
let's look at the best way of doing that
work out how we should do that in
conjunction with staff themselves and
then any costs she will be part of the
equation but the idea that we should
never look at doing things in a
different way or seeing if there's
improvements that can be made I think
that would be a mistake of course more
resources are required but we shouldn't
rule out reform of how we do things as
well okay um your boss seemed to get
himself in quite a pickle yesterday when
he was talking about patients making
self uh referrals
um do you think that's a good idea
I think it already exists in some uh
forms of treatment I think again if
we're having a consultation why not look
at uh how that could play a bigger role
not for everything clearly but for some
areas I think it could one of the real
problems I see quite regularly is the
the struggle tick to get to see a GP
because they're so uh under-resost and
because the capacity isn't there you've
got to obviously get in with a phone
call early in the morning that does put
more pressure on a e as more and more
people simply go straight to a e because
they don't feel they can get to see
their GP to do that so again if there's
different ways we can do that release
some of that pressure as a whole I think
everyone agrees you know as a National
Health System the NHS were in a position
too often where we're spending too much
on hospital care we're not getting in
with the treatments people need before
they get to that acute stage and again
if you're having a consultation about
the long-term future of the NHS in a
public model delivered in a public way
but looking at how it interacts with
patients again let's look at also new
ways of doing things as well as getting
more capacity and resources into it just
to be excuse me just to be absolutely
clear what does labor think at the top
table think we should do if we think we
have internal bleeding
I'm not going to get into specific
treatments and how they should be dealt
with this is the point you did yesterday
well look I think the best way forward
on this is to say we're looking at
different ways of how the NHS can work
we want to do a consultation with
patients with with GPS is the best way
to do that there are some treatments
where you can go immediately to
Specialists already we're looking at the
evidence around that but I think we've
got to address this this issue where so
much pressure is put into a knees as
people turn up presenting there because
they can't get to Access healthcare at
an earlier stage when it might be more
amenable to do that so I don't think we
should ever be in a position where we
are reluctant to talk about how we can
change a public service as long as it's
delivered in public hands in a public
way how is it interacting with patients
how can we do that better we shouldn't
shy away from that we put out very clear
plans and more resources for the NHS but
we've got to look at how it operates and
how it interacts with patients at the
same time yeah if I thought that I was
struggling with internal bleeding I'd be
straight on the phone to the doctor
wouldn't you
yes and I think no one is saying
anything that would take away the fact
that GPS will always be a major part of
the system but I do think there are some
things
that's what he said well I think there
was I think there are times when a
specific example from myself but I can
think of things where I've been
accessing treatment where I know what I
need because it's a repeat situation
where I think that could play a role but
look this is about a long-term future
plan for the NHS I think if we were just
highlighting the additional resources we
put in people would say well look we've
got a look at how it operates because
it's very difficult to be able to call
at 8am and get an appointment to see in
GP that is a real problem of the system
at present you know internal bleeding Mr
Reynolds is you know potentially
life-threatening he misspoke it's okay
to say if you misspeak
cool I understand you're flagging that
specific case and perhaps that is
something where you would always need to
go and see your GP but it doesn't
actually detract from the fact that what
we are putting forward is a labor party
who's looking forward to an election and
hopefully becoming the government is not
just a plan for more resources but a
plan for how we can make sure the NHS is
fit for the future delivers the kind of
care that people need Works in a way
that reflects our society and life
operates at present as well as giving it
the capacity and resources to do that to
me that is a long term plan for a
national public NHS and that should be
lauded and I think there'll be specific
things we need to talk about exactly how
it would work but reform and resources
that is what labor is putting forward
for the NHS just one quick thought
before I let you go uh Mr Reynolds who
just had a young woman on the program
from Scotland
um she said she knew when she was very
young
um that um she was born in the wrong
body we know that the gender Reform Bill
in Scotland means that those as young as
16
um can change gender and can have the
necessary paperwork to back that up
Scottish labor agree with that
does not agree with that what do you
think
16 is too young without parental consent
and my understanding is people do
sometimes transition younger than that
this is about whether that it's just
their decision alone or it's taken in
conjunction with their families I do
believe actually when that bill was
going through the Scottish Parliament
Scottish labor voted against the
reduction uh in age to 16. if I'm wrong
on that I'll apologize but I believe
that is how the passage of the bill went
forward so really it's about what age
can you do this alone rather than with
the support and understanding and
consent of your family we don't agree
with with the Scottish uh position in
its entirety but you know Devolution
means there will be different views on
its useful range of issues and that's
simply how the system works I think you
can reform uh the gender recognition
process whilst ensuring the equality act
and Single Sex spaces are preserved and
now this is labor party is UK position
it's always great to talk to you
hopefully see you soon Mr Reynolds thank
you